world famous touring down under and
kicking back at a five-star costing 28
thousand dollars a night it's a great
time to be Justin Bieber right wrong
[Music]
late for the star is an all five start
digs bungee jumps in singing mr. wendal
on a bike beans is currently enjoying a
calmer time in New Zealand after doing a
mob during his time in neighboring
Australia the major drama has now
divided believers with one-half
campaigning on line against the hordes
of young girls that made his life a
living hell leading with them to stay
calm and begging them to let him eat in
peace the pop star continues his love
hate relationship Trent with its fan
base which she instagrammed about last
summer at the height of the problem it's
gotten to the point that people won't
even say hi to me or recognize me as a
human I feel like a zoo animal perhaps
wishing he could take off Justin's also
revealed a brand-new tattoo of an eagle
across his chest with the new ink on
full display he stripped off for a dance
with a very different kind of fan at a
Queenstown bar